des amphis vide et davy saturé de
visioconférence un cauchemar pour ses
liens au verdon à tel point que
l'étudiant en licence protection et
valorisation du patrimoine a lancé une
pétition en janvier dernier pour
demander le retour des cours en
présentiel
il ya un moment dans ma formation où
j'étais en totale détresse et aux
rousses pas de motivation son décrochage
scolaire et la situation dans laquelle
j'étais mise en ne pouvant plus sortir
de chez moi en ayant trait pour en visio
en n'ayant plus aucune vie étudiante et
vit en dehors de 1000 pour et de ma
maison ça va coller dans des petites
angoisses et et c'était vraiment plus
vivable à partir du mois de décembre
depuis ces liens a pu retourner
totalement en cours dans sa promo la
moitié des étudiants restent chez eux et
l'autre moitié vient sur place soit
karimi est là encore tous ses courts
d'élèves infirmières à distance hormis
ces périodes de stage souad travail
prend ses repas se détend sans bouger
des 18 mètres carrés de son studio du
crous les courses s'enchaînent toute la
journée devant son ordinateur
alors pour rester motivé souad
compartiments de ces journées j'essaie
de pas trop tout mélanger même si des
fois ça m'arrive de mélanger le coin
nuit et le point cours mais j'essaie
globalement de cloisonner an plus tôt
finalement apprendre à distance cela
prend beaucoup plus de temps et
d'énergie
je vais devoir réviser je vois ça j'en
ai vraiment aucun souvenir parce que
j'étais pas s'ils en ont fuit à écouter
après ça se rattrape
c'est pas évident on met ça ça se
rattrape avec quelques heures de sommeil
ont pour elisabeth cette première année
universitaire c'était vraiment le grand
saut dans l'inconnu inscrits en droit à
lille elle a dû rendre son appartement
et revenir à besançon maintenant elle
retourne en cours une fois par semaine
indispensable pour appréhender une
matière que l'on n'étudie pas au lycée
c'est le retour en présence elle qui a
un peu sauvé mon année
étant donné que je me suis senti mieux à
partir du moment où j'ai pu avoir un
professeur en face de moi avoir des
camarades autour et on a pu vraiment
échanger sur comment vivaient les choses
et c'est vrai que maintenant je sais que
le droit est fait pour moi mais ça pas
du tout été facile au lycée elisa était
avec mathias künast en cours lui
s'étaient inscrits en première année
d'administration économique et sociale
donc pour vous la fac c'est fini oui
tout à fait c'est fini en fait il n'y
avait pas la relation la relation avec
le professeur s'il ya un problème il
nous explique etc etc
c'était en gros débrouillez vous et ça
c'était trop pour vous voilà c'était
trop matthias a décroché de la fac mais
il a trouvé sa voie pendant le
confinement dans le garage de la maison
familiale
j'ai découvert que j'aimais réparer les
vélos ou les restaurer que j'étais assez
bon dans ce domaine que ça pouvait être
à une idée de métier plus tard
l'histoire de cette génération qu'ovide
ne finit pas toujours aussi bien
la pétition de célia n'a rien donné le
retour sur les campus est encore limitée